[Music]
all right welcome to this second bonus
video this is the adventures of
pinocchio design so this was actually
supposed to go into the course
originally but i had to hold it for a
bonus video um
and the reason is because this
introduced some new issues and this is
some of the stuff that maybe you can
deal with in cinema 4d i'm sorry
i'm in after effects when you're dealing
with 3d layers
sometimes there's some headaches that
come along with it and this was one
that definitely gave me something to not
a headache but just something to think
about
and i had to do some creative problem
solving so
here is the
uh design that we're going to be dealing
with and it's a little
reveal
of this think of like maybe it's a
trailer for pinocchio
and this will be the end
tag
scene
and very very simple
but there's a lot going on here and i
love how
the light is illuminating
and kind of revealing this stuff
and we're actually faking 3d none of
this is actually 3d extruded text or
anything like that so
the original design though i want to
kind of walk through
what cameron and i talked about this was
the original design and this is i forget
the name of the designer who designed
this but
he made posters for this theater
and there was 3d extruded text and i
thought oh that's really cool
everything's flat except for this text
and you have the light in the top right
corner
the adventures of
and some dates and stuff down here so i
thought
let's recreate this
make it 3d and um kind of animate it and
there's there's just so much you could
do with this so i i love the design
so i went into photoshop
and
kind of mocked this up and the reason i
did it in photoshop is because i needed
to
composite the background here so
i went to unsplash
and
found this image this is a very famous
castle over in europe
and found this image a very very moody
night it's kind of backlit but very very
uh mystical
lighting here and just fantasy type
vibes all over the place
so next i cut out the sky
and a very soft kind of brushing and
feathering here
and i was okay to do that because
no i'm not going to say that
because
behind that is going to be the actual
sky
so this is just a sky image that i got
from
again unsplash or pixels something like
that
and drop that in there
and then behind all of that is this
texture layer
so i have all of these those are the
three main things that are kind of
working together and then i have another
texture layer over top
again all just kind of working if i turn
this texture layer over top it's just
adding a little bit of
extra texture there
and
that was the main composite and then i
added
a high pass filter some noise to really
get this grungy and just gritty feel to
it and then there's two paper textures
that are adding these little like white
specks around the edges here
so a lot a lot of texture
and
then i designed the typography in the
typography i have the pinocchio design
and i ended up using this made mirage
um typeface i've talked about made type
before in some of the other workshops
but if you go to behance and type in
maid type
hit enter and make sure you're over here
selecting people
and it'll be the first
there's only one made type but they are
absolutely
fantastic
designers when it comes to typefaces and
here is made um sorry mirage
so
comes with a few uh
it comes with five weights and it is
free for personal use but i suggest if
you use it
to if you go down to the bottom here
here's the download link for personal
use
but for personal and commercial work you
can go to font spring creative market
and on creative market it's 16
so not crazy priced and it's a really
really nice font
i own a lot of their fonts
and uh
yeah i i love
i love everything they do so that is the
typeface that i'm using for the main
pinocchio design
then i have if i double click on this
and open this up this is a
uh wood texture from adobe stocks free
collection and
snag that and that is clipped to the
typography
and then the adventures of that is a
typeface called enchanted land and that
is a free one if you just type in
enchant the enchanted land font
into google i think it was like from
dafont or something like that to
font.com
you'll be able to download that for free
and then i have it colored in this like
yellow mustard you know dirty mustard
type color
and it works together
so lastly i just added a little bit of
glow in photoshop and um
just kind of
blooming out the highlights and that was
the inspiration so
i had to figure out how to like how
what's the best way to build this in
after effects and i decided that let me
just kick out
the basic background
because that that's the basis for this
poster design right if i go back to
pinterest there's really nothing special
going on here it's just really well
executed
and it's a light interacting with a
piece of paper basically
and then this 3d extruded text so let me
export the background
and do everything else in after effects
so
just a quick background of where this
came from
and how we got here
and let's rebuild this
with a new comp
so i'm going to type in
i can name this whatever but i'm just
going to do bonus
video 2
and
tutorial
build
and
when you download the project file you
will get the original and what we're
going to build right now
and see how close i can get to the
original one
so uh 1920 1080 24 frames a second five
seconds of
five seconds duration and 3d render is
classic 3d
we're not going to be extruding anything
in
this one
so let's go to uh what is it pinocchio
background
and drag this in
and it's very large so let's right click
go to transform
and fit to comp width
and it's actually
wider
than the full hd so let's do this again
go to transform go to fit to comp height
and there you go now we're good
let's set it to 3d while we're here
and let's build the typography so
command t will get you your type tool
you can also go up here
and
click on the type tool make sure it's
the horizontal
type tool and type out pinocchio
remember we are on maid mirage and the
only other thing that i did from
hit p and just drag this over
this was the original
weight i designed it with made mirage
regular
but when i got into photo or after
effects
um
i changed this and i will show you why
in one second so
i'm going to leave this but we're going
to do that at 250 pixels
and no kerning and the
letting doesn't matter because we don't
have two lines
so
next let's go and hit the v key
just so we don't mess up our type
i want to hit command shift h
and
let's go to paragraph make sure that
we're centered up here
and then go to align and click center
and center
and
let's go to pan behind make sure
snapping is checked
and then i just want to center this up
so that now we're at 960 and 540
and
[Music]
then let's drag this up
and get it
something like that looks good
that works
maybe a little bit so maybe 380
380 in the y position
let's turn it to 3d while we're here
and then let's go to the adobe stock
this is the wood texture image
from adobe stock
let's drag it underneath
put it into 3d hit s for scale and drag
this down
until
it's just outside of our typography
layer so at 18
and then i want to parent this
to my type layer
and the reason i want to do that is
because
i'm going to be animating the position
of this type layer
and i want the wood texture
to move wherever this
i want all of this to be tied together
so the
next thing is the reason i have this
underneath is because i want to track
matte
and i want to alpha matte the pinocchio
layer
so now the typography is acting as a
stencil cutout
for the wood texture
this creates some
this creates issue number one because i
need to
have this text looks like it's
uh 3d
so what we can do is go to layer styles
and go to bevel and
emboss and if i turn this on
i get my bevel and emboss and it starts
to look like it's 3d and that's great
but i lose my wood texture
so what i can do is put this to overlay
blend mode and that is going to take
whatever differences in the text layer
and apply that to the wood texture
underneath
but
it takes the color
of the type
as well
so
let's go up here
i'm gonna bring this up a little bit in
the hue maybe like 12 degrees
and actually you know what let's just
leave it at zero
and i'm going to create
this like rose colored so i'm at zero
hue 32 saturation and a brightness of 76
and you can see
how this affects the color effects that
would texture underneath
so when i say 0 32
and 76
that works for me it gets a little bit
of this
redness back into the wood texture
and kind of allowed me to color it a
little bit
now let's work with our bevel and emboss
and this is
why i switched the weight of my typeface
so first thing i want to do here is set
the style to emboss
smooth is fine depth 100
direction up i'm going to set my size to
six
use
soften at zero use global light off
and the angle i'm going to set to 12
and that's going to create a highlight
on the right side
the right side of my typography on all
layers
remember i want my light to come from
the top right corner
exactly how this is done over here
so i need to match that with my bevel
and emboss
and
altitude's 30 degrees that's fine the
only thing i did then was i just took my
highlight opacity down
to 60 from 75
and this looks great
but
when you switch it too thin
i feel like it just levels it up and it
gives this elegance to it
if you click on your typography layer
this will work
and there we go
and i think the thin just i don't know
it has this elegance to it that i just
absolutely love and that was why
uh the original design changed
so
that is that
so now we can go and
create a new type layer i'm going to
type in the
adventures
of
and then set this to
enchanted land
and then i'm going to set this down to
50
but then set the kerning up to 160.
spread those letters out just a little
bit
and
hit p for position put this into 3d
and then i'm just going to move it over
and kind of align it with
the
edge of the p here and then keep it just
give it a little bit of space in there
and hit the v key
and that looks good maybe pull this down
just a little bit
that works then the only other thing
that i'm going to do is
command shift h to get rid of those
bounding boxes
i'm going to pull this up
and
get this a little bit
into this like yellow greenish area
and it's a nice contrast from the
background we have the very green
background up here and the orange down
here
so it's a nice it pops you can read it
looks good
so that is all of the design elements
now let's go get our lighting set up
and if i go to layer new
light
and i'm going to do a spotlight and
let's just click okay with those
settings right now let's get this light
set up in the position that we want to
kind of land in so
um
going to my four views here
and let's hit p for position
i'm gonna move my light using these
tools because if i use
this way you can see even on my top view
it's gonna move
the
point of interest as well and i don't
want that i want to keep that where it's
at if you move the numbers here see how
it kind of rotates around that point of
interest
and i'm going to move this let's
actually go to
uh one view go to top
and
turn this off and then hit command shift
h
and i'm gonna pull this
way out
um like 5000 pixels out
that works for me and then i'm going to
push it over
i'm going to push it over to the right
so i want it to be kind of over here a
little bit
and
i'm going to push that yeah maybe like 4
000 pixels that'll work
and then i'm going to push it up in the
y space now this i need to go back to my
active camera
and you can see now that
with it that far away it's
covering my entire scene
um
so i'm going to hit shift a a here again
turn this cone angle down
to
maybe 20 degrees that works
turn the cone feather up to 100
and then i'm going to drag this
into the negative so that it rises
and maybe like minus 900 or so
and
i like the position of that because it's
it's giving this little vignette here
and it's just kind of
coming right off the edge of that
typography
so
the only other thing let me hit a a here
and i can go to inverse squared on the
falloff
and drag this up
and i'm going to set my intensity to 200
percent and then drag this up so that
the light
hits
and around 4000 pixels looks good
and then let's leave that up and now i
want to introduce this shadow of
this typography so this is where the
main issue of this composition comes to
uh the forefront here with this design
and having the wood texture within the
typography i have an issue with the
shadow if i hit
a a here
you're gonna see what's gonna happen if
i turn cache shadows on
and
let's actually pull this
i'm gonna go minus 50
remember this is uh parented too so if i
move the type layer
the texture's moving as well
i'm going to pull back the adventures of
into minus 50 and it's just pulling at
50 pixels closer to our camera now i
have cast shadows on
on the
wood layer and that's what you're seeing
here
in the background if i turn that off
and hit a a for my typography layer and
turn cast shadows on
nothing happens
and that is the issue that i
i have i couldn't figure out a way to
get the shadow to cast into the
background
so the work around
is duplicate your
typography layer let's call this
shadow
layer pinocchio shadow layer i want to
pin this or parent it i'm sorry to my
original typography
i'm going to pull it underneath
everything
i want to right click go to layer styles
i want to remove all of the layer styles
and you see instantly
that
this
pops up with the shadow
so how does this work
if i hit a a
cast shadows is on
except shadows and accepts light is on
and as soon as i turn off that uh layer
style
you see that the shadow comes in to play
so what this is is
basically i'm
eliminating and i can pull this down
into black
and
it is set to overlay blend mode i can
set this to normal
and it's basically
just creating this shadow for me
if i turn this to
off
i can set this to cast shadows only and
now i have no
there's no typography it's just gonna be
the shadow of that
layer and that was my workaround
for that now the other thing is i did
leave the adventures of
i left that alone i did not put a shadow
on
that because it's regular typography i
didn't think it needed a shadow the
other thing too
that i played around with was with this
light and cast shadows on
the shadow darkness
i could crank this up
if i wanted to
and crank up the diffusion
so i'm gonna leave this as zero i'm
gonna put this back to 100
and leave it there for right now
and we might change it later on so let's
go up here to layer new camera and now
that we have all of this set up
let's get our animation going so i'm
going to set my camera to a yellow layer
and that way i can see
where it is in the comp
and i'm going to
change my
spotlight to be orange
and leave that at the top and then this
here i'm actually gonna hit command
shift y or
go up here to layer camera settings
and i'm gonna change this to a two node
camera
so if i go to two views horizontal i
want my point of interest here and i'm
going to kind of rotate around this it's
going to be a simple position
keyframe
so let's set a keyframe here and drag
this out to maybe four seconds that's
gonna be where our camera kind of
finishes off and let's drag this over
to the right
and let's zoom in
that works for me let's go to one view
that works so we're just kicking it off
to the side just a little bit and
let's go to uh i'm just gonna go to
third so i can start playing this
quickly you can see my shadow goes away
on that third but if i set it to full it
comes back
so maybe we'll go to yeah half it goes
away too
so
uh the shadow's still there
and
let's work with this light position as
well
i'm actually going to leave this on full
to animate this light because there's a
few things i want to change so i want to
change position but i want to
my point of interest is set directly to
this
layer here
and if i go to two views horizontal and
go to top view
i actually want to kind of set this out
a little bit here
so
you can see when i do that when i move
it away you get this
this effect here
and
what i want to do is
let's end this on that and let's pull
this
more to the side
let's make sure we're designing on this
yep okay
um
so i'm going to move that over just like
that
i'm looking at the shadow here and
it's not this far away in the original
design
so my position is off here for some
reason um
and i'm just gonna leave it at that for
right now but
this is a big thing of
make sure you place your light to get
the
shadow where you want it to be
um
but now uh let's animate the position
and i want to start it
closer
and get this shadow kind of moving
and also animate it closer that way
all right
and then let's go to
light
options want to hit
cone angle and cone feather and
intensity and i'm going to drag all of
these out while holding shift it'll snap
to where that last one was
and i want to pull this down
to
uh let's just go to zero
and
actually let's go to 100 just so i can
see what i'm doing i'm going to make
this pretty wide
and cone feather down to 50 percent
yeah let's do 12 down to zero
and now if i go to one view go to half
it's gonna kind of open up the light as
we are moving
our camera around
so
that works that's good
um
let's go to
the
pinocchio layer and adventure of and
let's hit p for position
and since they're both on 50 i want this
to go maybe like minus 250
and minus 150
ah maybe let's go like minus 125.
so they're gonna be moving
back
okay
all right and the last main thing we
have to animate here is on the
if i hit shift a a
oops i'm sorry not a a i want uh
uu
and it's going to give me the layer
styles what i want is the highlight
opacity
i want this to be
maybe we drag this out to two seconds
and around 12 frames let's take this
down
so that it is
i mean we'll start it off zero
so
basically i don't want the bevel and
emboss
to be introduced until
the lighting is introduced and that's
what i'm
that's what i'm uh getting at here with
this
the other thing is
uh
we can now
if you hit u you get all your keyframes
here
and what i want to do is just hit f9
to easy ease all of them but then some
of these i'm going to
change differently so this one i'm going
to pull back a little bit so that it
takes a little bit longer to get to full
strength
and then all of these other ones
i'm gonna pull all the way up
make zero
let's do the camera position
make this zero
and pull this
all the way up
that might be a little too aggressive
so maybe something like that
so i want it maybe it will do like an 80
influence you see the little
influence as i drag this so let's try
and keep it around 80
and i'll do that on this position one
you drag this handle while holding shift
you can get it down to 80 percent
influence
that works
i want to do it on the
position of pinocchio as well
make this zero
and make this one 80 percent
and eighty percent
select and drag and get all of these to
zero
so now we should have this camera motion
where
it kind of starts out
fast and slows down a little bit
now the only other thing is this
spotlight is way too dim so
let's go in here and take the intensity
up to
um
like 325
looks good
and the other thing is you see how this
um
wood texture it kind of looks weird in
the beginning here
so let's see if i can do t for opacity
and maybe just take the opacity
go to zero go to one second and take
this up then
maybe we'll go to two seconds
and then select this and same thing do
f9 to easy ease
and then take this oops
to like 80 that works
it'll keep it basically it'll just keep
it in the shadows a little bit longer
uh maybe pull this out to three seconds
yeah and that looks pretty good
so i want to watch the i'm watching the
highlight opacity and the opacity of the
wood texture layer
and make sure that everything looks good
with that which it does it looks like it
it looks pretty good
it's kind of both of them are being
introduced as the lights being
introduced
so the only other thing with this is um
you could go and now fine tune
everything so maybe we want to introduce
a little bit more color
into that typography
and
get it a little bit more of that warm
glow that we have
the other thing is
we can create the
command shift uh no
command option y
for an adjustment layer and let's call
this
grade
effects and
we can use two effects on here let's go
to glow
and
there's two types of glows that i want
to create i want to create a tight one
for the background
and um actually let's leave this on one
so we can see what we're doing here
and then see it's picking up a little
bit of this type in here too so
i want to play with my threshold
and see
where
i need to set this stuff
all right and i'm just pulling down the
threshold until i can see where it's
kind of interacting
so if i take this down
down down
maybe we'll do 49
take the glow radius way up like 150.
that looks good and then take the
intensity down to maybe like 0.2
all right let's duplicate this
let's take this threshold up and this is
going to be affecting kind of if i take
this back to 1.5
let's turn this first one off
i want to affect the typography and not
so much of the background on this last
one so let's pull this up
you see how it's it's hitting the
typography layers here so glow radius
let's pull out maybe like 40 and then
take the
intensity down
and maybe like 0.5
something like that 0.6
just to kick a little bit of glow in
there
i'll pull this up a little bit and go to
0.1
yeah
so just a little bit of glow in that
background
and then the last thing i added was just
a lumetri color
and all i did for this was
go to the creative tab
and i set it on this fuji f125 kodak2393
and it just introduces a ton of contrast
so
let's drop this way down maybe start
like something like 20
and that looks pretty good
so it's just kind of tightening this up
and making it punch a little bit
and then the basic correction i added
another 10
to the overall contrast and maybe we
could go 0.1
and brighten it up
just a little bit maybe like 0.2
and maybe we go to 25.
yeah
so that looks really really sharp i love
the effect of that and you can see
without the glows and the lumetri
now the glows may be a little hot down
here but i didn't want the background to
fall off
into nothing
so
you know maybe i pull this down to 0.08
and it just gets rid of that little
bubble there that was there
and uh yeah that is the
final effect so
you have your light turning on you have
the wood texture bringing up an opacity
you have the
uh bevel and emboss
getting stronger with the highlight
effect as the light gets brighter
and you have the camera rotating around
as well as the light moving and getting
stronger
so
a very simple animation
but a very effective one
so that is the
final animation
the only thing i might do is see i have
this parallaxing
and i actually might bring this down so
um
these are my two
this one's starting at the adventures i
was starting at minus 250 and maybe i
start that at like minus 175 i don't
want to
have it move so much like i want a
little bit of parallax i don't want it
to be completely different than the
pinocchio
i want them to move together
but they are moving back closer to the
background
which is at a position of zero
and with the light moving and the type
moving and the camera moving that's what
gives this nice effect between the
typography and the shadow layer
um
and you get some nice kind of
parallaxing and some nice motion there
so once again
i did
build it a little bit different than the
original one there's so many ways to do
these things and i don't know if i like
this one better
or if i like the original one better
but always fun to kind of experiment so
that is it for the entire course um
with the two bonus videos and i hope it
just shows that
there's so many possibilities you can do
with this uh it's just limited to what
your creativity can do and uh hope you
guys had fun learning and watching and
kind of
going on this journey with me into all
things 3d and with that that wraps up
this course
my name is ryan with motion science and
we will see you next time take it easy
[Music]
[Music]
you